Okay, so if you've taken a look at the vent management guide on the website, you'll notice
that there's a bunch of QR codes spread throughout the document.
Now, the idea here is that if you have a print version, rather than having to type in the
links for everything, you can just take your smartphone and scan the QR code and then open
up to whatever website it is.
So this first one that's on the cover page, it just takes you to my homepage.
So you can see that the QR code just takes you directly to RikerMedical.com.
Now moving forward, if you scroll down to some of the content, so let's skip on down
to just an arbitrary section, this one on dead space.
Go down to the bottom of the first page.
There's two links here.
So on the electronic version, you can just click the links and it'll take you to the
website, which is pretty cool.
But if you have a print version, you can also scan the QR code and it'll take you to the
website this way.
Now one thing with the QR codes is that they direct you from the image, so from this image
here directly to a URL.
And you notice that the URL that I used here is not the one at the website.
It's not this one here.
There's two reasons for that.
The first one is that the size of a QR code, like how many little black boxes in that white
background, it's a function of how long the URL is.
So if I did a QR code straight to this website, my QR code would be super detailed.
I'd have a bunch of little tiny dots and I wouldn't be able to make it as small.
Okay, so that's one reason.
The second reason is that things shift on the internet.
So right now, this webpage is at this URL, but if the host of this webpage decided that
they wanted to change the URL destination, my QR code here, if I link directly to that
URL and then it changed, it would give me like a broken link code, which I want to avoid.
So what I did was I made a QR code that links you to my website, a subdomain on my website
called references.ricoromedical.com slash the name of just like the little tag I added
on for that specific reference.
So that allows me to control where that QR code goes in the future if the URL changes.
It also allows me to make a QR code that's less detailed so I can put it smaller on the
print version.
Okay, so I'm going to walk you through the steps of how I did this.
So I use a QR code generator called QR code monkey.
My website is hosted on Wix and then I manage this subdomain on GoDaddy.
So we're going to walk through each of those steps one at a time.
So if you wanted to do something like this, you'll know how to do it on your document
or project or whatever it is you're working on.
I use a website called QR code monkey to make all of my QR codes.
So it's super simple to use.
You just go to the website here, come down here to your content and you put the destination
URL that you want and then come over onto the right, hit create QR code and then that
QR code will take you to whatever URL I put in.
Now just to demonstrate, I'm going to download this and scan it in with my smartphone app
here so I can show you how it works.
So I've got that QR code.
I bring this guy over top, scan it in and then I'm at my website.
Now I mentioned already that the problem with doing a QR code like this is that this image
here will forever and ever for the history of the internet take you to this URL.
But if I decide to change the name of my website or get a new URL, I have to make all new QR
codes.
That means if I have something in print, all those links will go to a broken website.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to use a QR code that goes permanently to a URL and
then from that URL I'm going to redirect it somewhere else and I can control that redirect.
Now there are services within QR code monkey or other QR code generators and they can build
you what are called dynamic QR codes which allow that same functionality.
The problem is that dynamic QR codes cost a lot to build because you're paying somebody
else to manage them.
They also typically come with other features as you can see here.
I decided I didn't need any of those features.
I just wanted to be able to build the QR codes and do the redirect on my own.
So that's where we're going to go from here.
The next step in this process is to set up your domain to do these redirects.
So go to GoDaddy.com, look on the drop down menu, come over to hosting, down to web hosting
and then the economy version of this works well enough for what we're doing here.
It's pretty cheap especially if you do over a longer term.
So just select that and then you do like a normal checkout, like a normal online purchase.
In that process you're going to pick your URL, like pick your name.
So for mine I chose references.writeyourmedical.com and then they assign you an IP address.
So here's my IP address.
Now you're going to take those two pieces of information over to, for me in my case
I do my website on Wix, I'm going to take those two pieces of information over to Wix
and then set it up so everything's linked together.
So I'm at my dashboard on Wix that come over here to manage domain and then click on this
little guy, manage DNS records and then in these first two fields, the one that's called
A host and C name, I want to put the information from GoDaddy onto here.
So in the first one under where it says A host, I'm going to add a record and then I
put my URL here and then my IP address.
And then under C name I'm going to add one, add a record that says cpanel.writeyourmedical.com
and then the value I'm going to do references.writeyourmedical.com.
That's the one that I chose on GoDaddy.
Okay, and then I save that and now I can go back to GoDaddy.
This is my dashboard there.
I want to go to file manager.
So file manager, come down to public, double click on that one and then the .htaccess is
the spot where we're going to do all of our building of these redirects.
So highlight that and click on edit and that's just acknowledging that you can mess things
up if you do this wrong.
And then here you can see all of my redirects.
So we'll just show you one example here.
So this first redirect I have, it's the redirect code and then I do backslash ARDS2000.html.
I leave a space and then I put the URL.
Now this links to an ARDSNET trial from 2000 and I'll just show you how that works.
So if I go over here to a new page, references.writeyourmedical.com slash ARDS2000.html, it takes you right
to the New England Journal of Medicine page where the original study was posted, which
is kind of cool.
Okay, so to show you how to build one from scratch, let's go back to our .htaccess page.
We'll go all the way down the bottom here and let's make a new line.
So we're going to type redirect space do a slash and we're going to go abc123.html,
leave a space, HTTP colon backslash backslash and we'll go to Google.
All right, and then save changes.
So now if I go here to references.writeyourmedical.com slash abc123.html, we get to Google.
All right, so that's how it works.
We start out at GoDaddy and we do the economy hosting plan.
We get that set up.
We take that information over to, in my case, I'm using Wix.
If you're using another platform to build your website, I'm sure there's a comparable
way.
I just don't know how to explain that one.
You take that information, your URL and your IP address over to Wix.
You plug it into that DNS server template.
So I did it here and here and then I can manage my .htaccess page and you can essentially add
as many of these things as you want.
They hardly take up any data.
So I think I have like 200 for this one project.
But as I built more projects, I just tagged them onto the end.
There's essentially no limit to how many of these things you can do, at least as I understand
this thing.
There's probably actually a limit.
So yeah, that's how it works up to this point.
Last step here is I'm just going to show you how to build one of these QR code references
from start to finish.
The video is going to play in double speed and I'm just going to kind of narrate it as
we go through.
So right now we're logging into Godaddy.com.
We already covered this.
So we're just going to go to our file manager and get to our .htaccess page so we can make
things happen.
And then when we get there, I organize all mine kind of alphabetically and there's like
a couple different sections.
So I'm going to find where this particular reference fits in alphabetically.
I'm going to type redirect space backslash and then whatever tag I want, .html.
And then I'm going to take the URL from the original source and put it in there.
And then I'll save it.
And then I'm going to go back to the Word document and add a link.
And there's a typo in here but I'll show you how that catches it.
So the link didn't work.
And there you go.
Now I can follow the link from my Word document and it works great.
So the next step is I want to build a QR code for that reference.
So using that reference is .ricormedical.com slash the tag that I made for MacIntire 2014.
I have a QR code and I'm just going to double check it on the computer now using this QR
code scanner app.
Awesome.
So that works.
And then I'm going to save this.
So rename the file and save it.
And then I'm going to go back to my Word document and insert that at the bottom of the page.
And then it's a little funky because it always comes to like the largest size possible and
you have to resize it and do a little bit of formatting.
And then since it is a reference cited, I got to go to the end to my references page
and do it over again real quick.
And you can see that like doing this references this way.
It's like a little bit more labor intensive than just doing like a standard work cited
references page because every time you add something you have to go back and reformat.
I imagine there's a way to do it where you can set it up to like automatically accommodate
this format.
I just haven't got that far.
So for now this is the way I'm doing it.
If you have any advice on how to make that happen, that would be greatly appreciated
for future versions.
And then the last step that I do is all these things that I'm linking to, I save copies
of them on my computer and that way if the content gets taken down from the internet,
for some reason it's no longer there, I can always host that.
For example, I can host this PDF, this paper on my website, keep the same QR code and
then redirect to a new location.
So there you have it.
That's how it works.
Very start to very finish.